- What's up, vlog?
As you guys know, if you're
really paying attention.
I haven't been investing a whole
bunch in the last 18 months
because I think consumer web
app, mobile app, you know,
next Twitter this, or the Uber that,
or the Air BnB of this,
or the Uber of that,
like, just boring, lot
of fake entrepreneurship.
But one place where I
see huge white space,
as you guys know, is voice,
and so I took this trip
to Seattle, to the
Techstars voice, kind of,
Amazon Alexa incubator, people
that are building on top of
the Alexa scale platform, and obviously,
they'll be building on top
of Google Home and Apple,
Home Pod as well, that to
me, is the white space.
And so, this talk is intriguing,
a little different look,
gives you a little bit
of my different mindset,
of, kind of, how I'm thinking
about entrepreneurship
and the white space of
complete platform shifts,
not the white space of the nuances
within a platform like social media.
So, really excited about it,
hope you enjoy it, and I'll see you soon.
(funky music)
- Obviously, Gary was at the forefront
of social, you watched all of that happen,
now, you're seeing similarities
in what's happening with voice,
we'd love to kick it off
about why you're here,
why you're excited,
what you're seeing
- Can I sit?
Can I sit?
- I would rather,
yeah, go sit there, I would rather
you guys be asking
questions rather than me,
if you don't, I will take up
all the time with my questions.
So, let's kick it off.
- Real pleasure to be
here, thanks for having me.
And even long before social,
I launched an e-commerce
wine business in 1996, right,
so, basically, the story
of my life has been,
pretty much, more
intuitive of what I think
people are gonna do,
not super data'ed out,
not super scientific
about it, just, kind of,
on my gut intuition,
actually taking it way back,
as a kid, I made a lot of
money selling baseball cards,
and the first time I really
remember this happening
was, I was at a baseball card show,
a normal thing that I would do
in my junior year of high school,
and for some reason, I just didn't like
the way the room felt, like, just,
it wasn't that I was calculating
how many people were showing up
or how much money people were spending,
I just didn't like the way it felt,
and literally, within a month,
I sold my entire collection
and poured all that money
into comic books and
toys, and that was right.
And, basically, intuition
in the wine business
that I grew up with,
you know, around Oregon,
and, you know, South American
and South African wines,
and so, that's always been my place,
and those spidey senses are
completely off the charts
in this space, and to
be very honest with you,
I'm not Nostrodamus, these spidey senses
are off to the races for you.
There's people that have
been doing this much longer.
It just, to me, I like to
get into a very specific time
in the lineage of a space.
I'm never smart enough
or scientific enough
to get in super early, thank you so much,
as entrepreneurs, as you guys
are, I think there's times
to get in super too early, for example,
in parallel, in our world,
there's a lot of people
tackling consumer VR, and think, like,
that's going to be super remarkable,
and for me, that's still
too early to be at scale,
and I think a lot of people
are gonna be not practical,
and waste a lot of money and time,
and I just think it's further away
before everybody's doing it.
And so, the things that
I'm seeing in this space,
is it feels that, I just
can't wrap my head around
a world, in America for sure,
and other parts of the world,
where, in 48 months, not
everybody's doing this.
And so, that's when it gets good.
That's when it gets practical.
And I'm also intrigued because I think
I've, personally, learned, and I'm sure
you as entrepreneurs and
innovators have learned,
we've learned a lot about
building on top of systems,
whether the Apple ecosystem,
things of that nature,
so it's going to be interesting
how this all transpires.
But for me, it's just, it's time,
it's time for me to get educated,
it's time for me to make bets, it's time
for me to make things,
it's time for me to come
and spend, in a world where
I'm hacking every five minutes,
you know, I wanted to schlep here,
and I'm thankful for the opportunity
to hang with you guys and gals, and so,
it just, in the Gary, in one
human being's personal radar,
it's now just a matter of time,
and if, the biggest thing in this room,
especially if I get the
luxury to spend some time
with you guys individually, to me,
it's just about staying
alive until it gets good.
The biggest thing that, I think,
you will get caught with,
and I've seen over and over,
is, are you running it practically?
Are you at the mercy of VC,
or this incubator, or anything else?
Are you at the mercy of anything
over the next 36 months?
Are you capable of
understanding what it takes
to do over the next 36 months?
Because you're right.
Like, your brain is
100%, you're 100% right.
Now there's just two variables.
Can you be there when it happens,
and is there somebody else
that can do the same
thing better than you?
That's it.
And so, I think that's
great, because I don't think
there's a lot of spaces in
the world that look like that.
So I think you've won the
better part of the bet,
which is the global strategy
of what you're gonna do
with your time in your life.
Now it's about those two variables.
That's what I would be
spending all my time on,
that's what I do spend all my time on.
- [Facilitator] Are there
any specific moments
that you either had with
a voice-assisted device
or you watched someone else have,
that kind of clicked in your head
in terms of, whoa, this
is gonna become something.
- No.
Nope, nothing like that.
You know, I kind of was
watching and knowing
and seeing, and got a device,
and saw other people had a device,
you know, there was no magic moment.
To me, I only believe that
there are only a couple of
things that matter to people.
Health and money and
religion, and I think time
is way up there.
And anybody who can't
put the pieces together
to understand why voice and time
are a really interesting variable,
are just missing this whole point.
So it's inconceivable, to me, anything,
Uber, I passed on Uber
twice in the angel round.
You know, if you go, if
you open my first book,
the only person I thank besides my family
is Travis, we were really
good friends long before Uber.
You know, I didn't invest in it,
and, that, I did have a moment.
When he came to New York
to ask for some help
to think about how to launch
New York as a second market,
my brother AJ and I were meeting with him,
and he's like, "Hey,
we've got, like, a test
alpha car in the market, can you try it?"
And AJ ordered the Uber while we were,
there was something, I
don't know why that hit me,
but there was something
that didn't happen to me
in San Francisco, that
AJ being in a high rise
in New York, hitting a
button, and it, like,
saving that time, made me realize that day
that Uber was selling time,
not selling transportation.
So, that's when I started
getting really crazy about time.
I'd always been about lack of friction
and things of that nature, but because
all the way back in 2010-11,
time got crazy important to me,
when the voice thing started
becoming more on my radar,
I mean, it's just such an incredible play,
and so, there was no one thing,
but it was just the complete passion
of, how do we save people time?
People always pay for
time, time will always win.
- [Facilitator] Yeah, and
I think that's one thing
that all the companies in here
have been looking for, right, is that,
what is that magic moment
with these platforms
that gets people to actually, you know,
have those, that click.
That, like, "This is
the new way to do this."
- So I would go about it a
little bit different way,
you know, if that's a
conversation you're having,
I think the people in
here that will succeed
are the ones who spend no time on that.
I think you just need to basically, like,
that sounds like debating
things that mean nothing to me.
Meaning, do you believe that
every single fucking person
is gonna have a device in
their home in 48 months?
And I think that answer is yes.
And so, then, who gives
a shit what moment,
what commercial, what app, does that?
To me, it's cool, I've
assumed that to be true,
how do I create what I want
to create in that truth,
and how do I make sure that I'm there?
- [Facilitator] And as you, kind of,
look at the parallels of that happening,
and a lot of times, people
try and drop to, like,
when the iPhone first
came out, and suddenly,
people have these devices,
you know, in their pockets,
and the first things that happen there
tend to be games, entertainment,
as you think about these
cases in the future
that you get excited
about, what are those?
- That's a good question.
I mean, I'm very, very excited
on a couple of things
that are personal, I just,
how many people here know
somebody that's really
into wine, raise your hand.
Perfect.
So, when somebody gets just a
little bit of wine knowledge,
they become a straight douchebag.
(audience laughs)
So, I've been on a decade journey
to, like, demystify wine.
I'm really excited about, you know,
the idea of people
being able to be at home
and tasting wine along with me,
and being educated and learning,
I think there's a lot
of that kind of stuff,
I love the idea of people learning
how to fix their car motor, because
there's an expert right next to them.
So, the expert space excites me a lot.
Like, when you really play it out,
the chess moves, when it
gets that sophisticated,
we're gonna be able to
have that communication,
I think that's super fascinating,
I think you guys are
thinking about that right,
if that's the conversation, I think,
there's complete pattern recognition
into what things play first,
and I do think what you're
talking about is called,
in my mind, escapism, right,
something that, like,
takes me away from the fact
that the world is difficult,
or my personal world is difficult,
and that's entertainment and gaming,
things that just take
me out of my real life,
those are always very
fruitful first places to play,
because, A, you have a creative set
of people who are usually playing,
so yeah, I can see that.
But I do think the expert
space is intriguing.
The person that makes the first app
that is really, you know, advanced,
and can really help somebody either
really learn something, cooking, you know,
that's why I love IP,
like, I'd love to be owning
Julia Child's IP right now, right?
You could do something really remarkable
and I'm sure her family
never thought, years ago,
that it'd be deployed against
a voice infrastructure
and she'd be helping the world
learn how to make souffle.
- [Facilitator] So, last one from me,
so get your questions ready,
there is no one from Amazon
in the room currently,
but when you look at the
different platforms of Amazon,
Google...
- Yep.
- [Facilitator] Who do you
think has the advantage here,
why, have you thought about that?
- Yeah, so this is the great part
about filming everything you fucking do,
I, I've only been really
aggressively booed onstage,
and I curse, and I'm crass,
and I'm a lot of things
that people don't like, at times, onstage,
but the only time I was
really aggressively booed
was at South by Southwest when I said
that Jeff Bezos was
better than Steve Jobs,
back in, like, 2010-11, like bad.
Yeah, I think, I'm a very
big, big, big, big Amazon fan.
I just think, you know,
only the government
can really stop him.
(audience laughs)
So, I think they're gonna really play,
I'm less confident that Google and Apple
are gonna be great at it, I really am.
And then, it'd be cool, you know,
for me, it'd be really cool if there was
somebody who emerged that doesn't exist.
Or, we, or, you know what'd
be really cool for me,
I like that Nintendo started
as a playing card company.
Wouldn't it be neat if one
of these big conglomerate,
big companies, finally realized
that they should be putting
themselves out of business
instead of letting somebody else do it,
and took all those dollars they had
and bet it on where the world's going?
So, like, why couldn't BMW be a player?
They could.
THey're just not built to do that,
but that would be rad,
if somebody got smart.
- [Facilitator] Turning it over.
Who wants to dive in first?
- Yes, sir.
What's your name?
- [Brian] Brian (mumbles).
- Brian, real pleasure.
And by the way, Brian, I apologize,
but for the whole group, also, like,
I've done a lot of investing, like,
if you want to go on the business side,
not just on the creative
side of what you're doing,
feel free to raise your hand.
Go ahead, Brian.
- [Brian] So, topic is
surviving that 36 months.
- Yeah.
- And um...
- You like that thesis?
- [Brian] What's that?
- Is that a good thought,
like, do you see that?
- [Brian] Well, as a topic,
and one of the things
we've been doing here in the cohort
is really sharpening
our measurement skills.
- Okay.
- Right now,
like over a five day period, you know,
what are those, kind of, three categories
of things that you're
gonna measure yourself,
week over week, you know, leading towards
the demo day coming up.
- Yes.
- And we pushed out a little further,
and surviving to those 36 months...
- It gets harder.
- It gets harder, right?
- There's only a couple
things I think I understand,
and this is one of them.
I am stunned by the fact
that most people build
financial arbitrage
machines, not companies.
Just spending all their fucking time
thinking about how to do things
to make the next fundraising event happen
so they can stay alive.
I think, I think start-ups
in today's environment,
10 years of good times since
the bad era of the economy,
are way too fucking fancy.
Like, why can't you
have a service business?
Like, why couldn't you hire two people
instead of two less
developers, which will take you
nine months longer to
achieve your tech goals,
but you could hire two people
who could do client work
or consulting for companies
so you have cash coming in.
There's a binary decision in
advanced technology companies
that are start-ups
that, the way it's done,
is you raise capital, you burn through it,
you raise capital, you burn through it,
and you have your event, right,
you either become a profitable
company or you sell.
The fact that there's
no practical parallel
of, "Well, what else could we be doing,"
like, what if there was no venture money?
Like, what do you think happens
when the markets collapse?
These companies figure it out.
When you're as lucky,
you guys aren't mobile
or social companies, you're
playing in a new field.
Nobody knows anything about it.
Which means that there's enormous appetite
for the leaders to pay
for a knowledge transfer.
And so, my biggest thing is, first of all,
forget about the people you
surround yourself, you guys.
Everything's your fault.
You're the founders.
You need to be in charge
of having a real, structured strategy
to how to stay alive,
and everybody's rushing
to make the product, or to do this thing,
and, to me, it's like,
give up six months of that,
to do something that's making you
practical dollars along the way.
It's just something nobody
ever wants to talk about,
because everyone's so
fucking fancy, Brian.
You know?
Everyone's fancy.
Like, and I just think that's stupid.
I also think it's compoundly stupid
after nine years of
good economy, you know,
I mean, the only thing that I think
makes me not think that
the markets would collapse
in the next three years during this era,
is that, I think, we have a
president who would do anything
to manipulate the economy
not to fall during his time.
Other than that, I mean, this
is a long run of prosperity.
And, nobody's running businesses
like they're businesses
because there's artificial
dollars in the system.
There's incubators.
There's all this shit.
So, I would think about
how to not waste money,
and how to make money along the way,
while achieving your business goals.
And I know that that's
just not the kind of talk
that's going on in our world.
- [Audience Member] That's awesome.
- Yes, sir, what's your name?
- [Alex] Alex.
- Alex.
- [Alex] From (mumbles).
Do you see, so, speakers, smart speakers,
going into homes real quick, the voices
across a bunch of other
platforms, you know,
you could get it for your TV.
- Yes.
I agree.
- Do you have a view on whether the, like,
propagation of smart
speakers is gonna peter out,
and where it's gonna (mumbles),
sweep into something else?
Like, where do you see voice,
fitting in.
- Yeah.
With the speakers, from
a speaker standpoint.
So, for example, do you know who I think
should be making the single
biggest bet in this space?
The Toll Brothers construction company.
I mean, every home built going forward
should have an upcharge,
huge profit margin for them,
where they're like, "You
don't need those speakers,
it's just in!"
Right?
Security systems, right?
The people that secure your
homes, things of that nature.
So, yeah, I'm not, I'm sure there's,
I haven't done the homework on this,
I'm sure there's clearly
an intriguing window
for the hardware in that form,
but I think that's commoditized,
and there's a lot of things
that can deliver that,
and I do think that that's dangerous,
other than if you have great tech
that can then be put into a wall
or a bottled water, or what-have-you,
but, like, as a
consumer-facing speaker play,
I think there'll be a window,
but over time, that gets commoditized,
so you have to, I don't
love when you have to,
not only all the things
we just talked about,
but then the macro consumer
behavior moment, as well,
that adds another layer of timing
which usually forces
you to be less patient,
which is what I was talking
about, right, Brian?
Like, now you're forcing
it because you know,
"Shit, we've got 24 months before," right?
So, yeah, I would, I'm far more bullish
on the people who have got
the tech or the infrastructure
around what's making it sound great,
more so than the physical
product, you know,
I think that just plays
out, you know, right?
I mean, Amazon's,
Amazon and everybody else should be making
a smart refrigerator that
has speakers built into it
so that, not only is it fully
penetrating your kitchen,
but it's reordering every product for you
once you've used up a
percentage of that product
inside the refrigerator.
- [Male Entrepreneur] So, you mentioned
at the start of these spaces,
there's a, you know, an opportunity
for start-ups like the ones we have here
to work with a knowledge transfer
to some of those larger organizations.
- Yeah.
- [Male Entrepreneur] But,
there's also a another thing,
which some of these companies are
starting to experience too,
is that these larger companies
who don't understand
the space are thinking,
"Are you acquisition targets?"
And, you know, how would you, kind of,
advise me to think about,
sticking it out for the long run,
you take a quick win,
what does that look like?
- Yeah, I mean, I think the
cool answer to that question
is that that's very
specific to you, right,
there's no right answer to that.
What I love, as you were
talking, like, "Fuck,
I should have brought up that point too,"
because that doubles up the reason
why to be practical and have
a parallel service business
that's bringing you revenue in,
because it's probably the gateway
to a more significant
acquisition opportunity
because they get to lease before they buy
and understand that you're
smart and you get it.
And we've seen through the history,
if you're here to make,
make that financial nut,
you know, the amount of ACU hires,
we've seen some ungodly, we saw on social,
ungodly exits, where the guy
or the gal was getting bought.
I think that actually doubles up
why I think you should go in,
but, like, it's up to you if you,
if Coca-Cola, you're
doing a project for them
in parallel while you build your thing,
and they want to offer
you seven million dollars,
I mean, that's just, or
70, or seven billion,
I mean, I think that's,
I think at seven billion,
a lot more people here would go for it,
(audience laughs)
um, I think, I think the
punchline there being,
everybody here has their own circumstance.
You know, for me, I had, a
long, long, long time ago,
far less money than I have now,
that was the money I wanted to make.
Then it became about legacy, like,
playing the game, and a lot
of different things, right?
Not, some people want to amass
dollars their whole life,
some people want, don't wanna
have, don't like the idea
of earning out for three years
because they think, I
would be very empathetic
if I became best friends
with everybody here,
and a year from now,
everybody gets an offer,
I could really see that tough decision
of like, fuck, this is
life-changing money,
and this is my, you know,
this would be helpful for me,
but I'm locked up for
three years, and fuck,
these next three years in this space?
They're so fruitful.
So, I don't think there's
a one-size-fits-all,
and some people have student loans
and sick parents, and you
get into a million variables.
They both work.
The amount of people that said no,
in the 1.0, Web 2.0, and social bubble,
and ended up with dickshit,
is a lot.
The amount of people that said yes,
Instagram and others,
could have gotten a lot more.
Bebo's super happy they sold for
850 million dollars to AOL.
(audience laughs)
You know?
You know, so, you know, I, I think
there's a lot of ways that goes.
I think that's where you
go, that's where you,
I get really worried that mentorship is,
mentorship is so important, but it can be
substantially overrated, because mentors
tend to love to give the
advice that they lived through,
or they don't contextualize
all these human variables
that I just brought up, so, the
answer would be all of them.
However, I'm a big fan of options.
So, I sure love the idea of
you making money along the way,
that also led to an MNA opportunity,
it's a lot more fun to
have options than not.
- [Male Entrepreneur]
I'll take this one, then.
- Okay.
- [Male Entrepreneur]
So, you know, a lot of
what you've done over the past, you know,
decade or so, social, recognizing
how this was gonna change
customer service, customer
experience, and, you know,
require more authenticity, you know,
we're not necessarily just
talking about it with voice,
I'm just curious how you, kind of,
came to a lot of those conclusions
and navigated those
and built your business
is really where I'm at.
- You know,
it's funny, I think we all, right,
like, your experiences lead to everything.
I grew up in a retail liquor store.
And I would tell you that voice,
I can already make the pieces
all the way backwards to it.
Like, customers don't
like waiting in line.
Nobody likes friction.
And, retail's a real good place,
because it's one thing if
you're a UI/UX data nerd,
and you're just looking at it.
It's a whole 'nother thing when
you see the person's venom in their eyes.
And it, it got ingrained
in me so early on.
And I'm a depth versus width guy,
even though I love width and it's why I do
so much of my schtick,
it's still the depth,
it's always the depth.
So, you know, what I knew about social
was what I knew about email.
I, early, it's just experience,
pattern recognition,
early email, I bought a ad on
luxury.com's email newsletter,
they had a million emails newsletter,
and, like, they print their,
you know, this is what's
fun about being old,
this stuff used to be wild.
Like, "You have a million emails?"
It was like (imitates explosion).
You know, like, it was
crazy, I paid a fortune.
Like, we were such a small company,
I think it was like five
or 10 thousand dollars,
which was, like, a lot.
And I called my high school
friends to come into the store,
because they were sending
the email, on their email,
the banner ad, which,
you know, at the point,
at that point, there was some banner stuff
I was running on the web in '96
that was getting 14% click-through.
Not .00, you know, like,
it was a different world,
as it always will.
As will the next three
years of consumer-voice be
compared to 10 years from now.
You guys are all gonna
convert in a way that,
people be, like, one day, like,
"When I had five thousand
Twitter followers,
I'd get more retweets than
when I had a million."
It's just how it works a lot, right?
Anyway, nonetheless, I had
hired four extra people,
brought like seven
friends, I thought we'd be
packing and shipping all day,
we were such a small shop,
and 12 o'clock is when
it was gonna go out,
and it's 12:13, and we
have, like, one order.
And I'm like, like, devastated,
trying to figure out, and then, I,
I'll never forget this moment,
I'm like, "Oh, I'm such an idiot!
It's nine o'clock in the
morning on the West Coast!
It's, you know, not twelve!"
You know, so.
So, I feel better for about 45 minutes
until I get an email from
this guy who's sold me the ad,
and he's like, "How's it going?"
Because they did send it
at 9:00am, twelve my time,
and I'm like, like, you
know when you have those,
you know when blood rushes to your head
and you can almost faint (laughs),
you know, like, I was like,
"Oh, shit, I'm in trouble,"
it was when I realized, huh, open rates,
and, you know, I didn't call it that, but,
open rates and click-through
ratios were gonna matter, too,
not just how many you had.
And, basically since then, and
why I did so well in social,
was that was my second rodeo.
I know that's when people got to know me,
but that was my second rodeo.
I learned a lot about
shopping cart optimization
and email, and so, I
think about the depth,
not just the width, you know,
you're not gonna care
how many people have it,
you're gonna care about how many people
do the right thing with it,
and so, I think a lot about that stuff,
that's how I think about,
why do I care about customer service?
Because it's depth.
Basically, I think about
things very simply.
I'm a really great marketer,
that's what I'll be known for,
but if your product blows,
all my great marketing is gonna do
is expose it quicker.
The product is the product is the product.
It matters.
You know?
And we do all these things around it
to make it seem like it
doesn't, but it does,
and to me, depth and customer service,
you could have ten
thousand followers, and?
Right?
- Yep.
- Nobody's paying their mortgage on likes.
So you've gotta figure out
what metrics matter, right?
Watch what happens in the podcast space
once all the data comes out now, right?
Because, you know, cool, you got in early
and got a lot of subscriptions,
and they haven't unsubscribed.
Right?
So a lot of people are
about to be exposed.
- [Male Entrepreneur] As you think about
how you built up your career, which,
it sounds like, I mean, it
was pattern recognition,
you saw this work there, and again,
now you've reached a point where
you're not just doing
that for your own career,
you're investing across
different companies.
- Yep.
- [Male Entrepreneur] If
you could talk a bit about,
you know, how you, how you
kind of evaluate companies,
what you've learned, now,
as an investor (mumbles).
- The first three things
I put my money into
were Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr.
That's when I was not an investor.
So, I don't like talking
about myself as an investor
because I got progressively stupider.
Which is why I gave you
the advice that I gave you.
What I've learned the last six years is,
first of all, it's about
the jockey, not the horse.
I'm far more interested about knowing you
and what you're about and how you roll,
because you've gotta pivot and change,
and you know this,
like, listen, if your
idea's stupid, like, right?
If your horse is, like, you know, a horse,
those machines you put the quarter in,
and you've gotta actually run
a race, you're gonna lose.
Like, you know.
But, but it's stunning
how important the CEO is.
How important she and he is.
It's stunning for me,
six, seven years later.
Especially in this time,
because you're gonna have to change.
Like, this, you know what's funny
about a new space like this?
Some of the biggest wins are the ones
that go from b to b, to
b to c, and vice versa.
Like, literally just change
your fucking business.
And you, as a CEO, have
to be the kind of person
that can react to reality, versus,
you're obsessed with the
romance of your vision.
So, I'm spending a lot of time
trying to get to know the person,
Phil and I, Phil, Toronto, here,
who's done, who started as my assistant,
does a lot of investing, and helped me
run my last fund, not even invest,
we haven't even invested in the last year,
poor Phil was like, wants
to punch me in the face.
(audience laughs)
You know, like, because we
think things are overinflated,
everybody's a fucking entrepreneur,
everything's an idea, I mean, guys,
let me just break it down for you,
and I know you're in it,
and I'm in it too, like,
like, if you knew nothing,
it is kind of interesting
that an idea is worth four
to five million dollars.
That is what we're talking about.
So it's very interesting times,
and I think, I'm glad, Brian's question,
we started with that, what
I'm looking for especially,
because I want to invest in this space,
who can get there in 36 months.
Who can survive.
And that's it, because it's too early
for it to hit too much.
And there's too much that's unknown still,
and you're still, I, you know, obviously,
I've got the advantage of sitting with you
for a few seconds, I'm
super pumped to hear
how many people are diverse,
you know, and smart,
and I figured that, I mean, I didn't think
this was gonna be about just
building skills and briefings,
but I'm excited to get, and by the way,
I'm excited to get educated,
myself, about, like,
the layers of, like, thinking against,
not being at the mercy of the platforms
or how do you go around it.
And then there's just,
like, the things I remember,
like, you know, you just thought
Yahoo was gonna be the browser.
You know, when I was, like,
there was no thought that
there was really even a chance
of a Google coming along, you know?
So it's cool.
One of the things that I'm
very fascinated about is,
it seems so clear who's gonna win this,
or who's gonna be the platforms,
I've an enormous amount of curiosity of,
is there somebody that
we're not thinking about
jumping in, you know?
So, I'm looking for people
that are aligned with me,
specifically in this
space, of like, yeah, like,
I really have to be thinking
about 36 months from now,
there's just not gonna be enough users,
enough discoverability, enough adoption,
and so, what am I gonna do about it?
And anybody who's just
gonna rely on, you know,
the demo day, or the
introductions you guys make,
or they're gonna raise some capital,
is fine, and I'll probably
miss some good ones,
because that is an absolute
blueprint to success,
I guess I'm just looking
for a little more ghetto.
A little more scrappiness, you know?
Somebody who's so obsessed
with this being their lives.
Do you know how many people
are gonna be happily,
you know what bugs me the most?
Is if, tomorrow, it all melted,
I have millions of dollars
sitting in the system in limbo,
I'm just gonna get emails that are like,
"Hey, Gary, as you know,
the world collapsed,
you know, super sad it didn't work out,
fucking sucks, Trump, what a dick, huh?
And, yeah, I'm going to business school,
so we'll be shutting down next week.
Need you to sign these."
- I learned a lot.
- What?
- [Phil] I learned a lot.
- Well, Phil's bringing
up a story that I will,
I wasn't even gonna go
there, because honestly,
like, you just said.
- Go there, go there.
- Dude, my fucking, he just said it,
and the insides of my stomach went hot.
This dude sat in front of me,
I'm, listen, I get that I've done it,
but I lived in a studio apartment
with eight family members
when we came to America.
Like, I had zero vacation
days in my life in my 20s.
I worked so hard to where I am now.
This dude sits in front of me,
I wrote him a $150,000 check, personal,
and goes, "Look, we're gonna
be shutting down the company."
Meanwhile, you have to
understand, complete left field,
like, literally a week earlier,
dude's taking photos at Coachella.
And he goes, "Look, we're
gonna be shutting it down,
just wanted to thank you, you know,
like, just need you to sign some docs."
He goes, so I'm like, kinda sitting there,
I'm like, you know,
I'm, like, disappointed,
but not, like, dead, I
mean, I've lost a lot,
it wasn't that,
but then it got crazy.
He goes, before I said anything, he goes,
"No, no, no, don't worry.
I learned a lot."
(audience laughs)
I was just like,
you know, so, so I think,
I don't, I'm not looking for that anymore.
He learned a lot.
- [Brit] (mumbles) after he said that.
(audience laughs)
- You know what, he didn't, because,
I avert, if I had my dad's
personality, he would have.
I'm more, like, kind of like, silent,
but, I, like, ate it,
you're right, he lost, because,
and he lost with all the investors,
and these were, like, important,
you know, he was lucky, you know,
he was charismatic, he
was, it was that schtick.
He had a lot of the good angels on it,
and, losing your name is so crazy.
But, and that's what's about to happen.
Whatever happens, there's so much,
there's ungodly amounts of non-businesses
in our world of start-up,
across all sectors,
people are gonna go back to McKinsey
and go back to Harvard Business School.
- [Male Entrepreneur] So,
I wanna add onto that.
I had a experience a week ago
with a founder, who just had the idea,
was raising two million on a knee,
but only wanted to work with investors
who invested in founders.
And after that one hour coffee meeting,
I had to decide whether or
not I was gonna invest in him
because there was so much interest in him.
- Right.
- [Male Entrepreneur] How
do you kind of reconcile
the, you know, investing in people,
and kind of the timeline (mumbles),
like, how do you get to
know founders, how do you?
- I run the gamut.
My team will tell you that I pick
too intuitively and too quick.
Sometimes I can make a
decision in one second.
I basically married my wife
eight seconds into knowing her,
you know, so I can be
pretty intuitive that way.
However, I look for cues.
Anybody that would tell me that
that was the rules of the engagement,
I would tell them to go fuck themselves.
You know, like, you're not
gonna put a time limit on it,
you know what I mean?
Like, you could have
told me after the fact,
or after we had a nice meal,
you could have emailed
me kindly and been like,
"Hey, I'm, I've got pressure,
and I'm gonna move,"
but, like, that's just his psychology move
to get people to make
irrational decisions,
which means I don't like you.
You know what I mean?
So, but, yeah, I can run the gamut.
Sometimes it's people you've
known for a very long time,
other times, it's just, you know, right?
The reason you like a song
the first time you hear it,
or fell in love, or
found your partner here.
It doesn't have to be that complicated.
I'm overly intuitive
and not analytical, so,
you know, mine tend to be quick,
or intuitive, and I'm okay
with that, as long, you know,
I'm sure for the people that
have been successful like me
with that style, your wins
so outweigh your losses,
so you win in a macro.
I like, you know, one
thing I would tell you,
whether you're like me or
completely the other way
and everything's gotta be about the math,
or, anything in between,
it's just so much more fun
to die on your sword
than on somebody else's.
So, regardless of what, I think I'm
a pretty compelling communicator,
if this is not intuitively
what you believe, like,
let it be.
You know, like, there's gonna be plenty
of voices coming through
here, plenty of opinions,
if I could leave you with anything,
just die on your own sword, it's better.
Because then you don't have regret,
and regret is poison.
- [Male Entrepreneur] I wanna
ask a bunch more questions.
Did you have to get,
- What's that?
- [Male Entrepreneur] This
is kind of, a little fanboy.
- Please, go anywhere.
- I was wondering if you could apply
some of what you're saying to, like,
the Wine Library TV days, because for me,
like, that was life-changing.
Not only because I'd had a wine snob dad,
I was willing to talk
different about wine,
but also, I think it's,
like, a good, for me,
in my mind, to get practical (mumbles)
of applying some of this to survival,
- Hundred percent.
- it's a great example I know.
So if you could talk about
- Of course, man.
- A funny anecdote to that.
- First of all, anybody else
that wants to recall those things,
it makes me feel amazing, so thank you.
Look, that was a perfect example.
I saw YouTube, it was four months old,
nobody knew what the hell it was,
and, in one second of looking at it,
I'm like, "This is gonna
fucking change the world."
And, I, you know, I
had never given a talk,
you know, now this seems insane,
but I'm 30 years old and I've
never given a public talk,
I never was in front of a camera,
I was a businessman.
Like, I didn't, you know?
I was a good salesman, that's,
that's where this schtick
came from, but, like,
so, why, I thought it was a good idea
to send one of my stock guys to Best Buy
and get a camera and start a wine show,
and the truth is, I immediately, you know,
I am who I am, I thought
I was gonna do QVC.
I thought he was gonna come back,
I was gonna pick three wines
that we were sitting on
that weren't moving or
whatever the fuck, right,
put them in a camera and go.
And literally, from day
one, he's setting up,
we're setting up the table,
I switch out the wines,
I go with some premium, I know
what they are, Vérité Wines,
some real high-end wines,
and the light goes on in the camera,
and I'm like, "Fuck, man.
If I go to a party in a
year," this is all going,
you know how fast, you could
think of a million things
really fast sometimes, "If
I go to a party in a year,
and somebody hands me a glass of wine
and says, 'Hey, try this, do you like it,'
I have to, basically, not be wrong.
It can't be something that
I told them was phenomenal
and I'm like, this is shit."
So, basically, as I'm going, like,
as I'm in the first minute, you know,
it's funny, if I watch
Wine Library episode one,
and I made a thousand of them,
to give you guys context,
I know exactly the moment
in the first five minutes
where I made the decision,
"Fuck, no selling."
Every episode for the rest of my life,
and it caused me so much headaches,
talk about the long game,
I lost relationships,
you know, there's people you
do business with for 11 years,
and you saw it, you know
how I did that show.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, this wine
tastes like a cow shit in your face.
You know, like, they don't like that.
You know, like, and so,
it was super interesting,
and nobody watched it
for the first 17 months
that I did it, nobody watched it.
Just, nobody watched it.
And, for the first eight years that I,
2006, 1998, for the first eight years
that I ran my dad's wine business,
every month, the revenue
grew more than 20%
from the year prior's monthly revenue.
Every month.
And 50, 70, 100, but never
a month that wasn't 20.
The first month that I did
Wine Library TV, it was flat.
And then it started declining
because all of my energy was going.
And so, you know, I was, you know,
that was a different level of survival
than what you're dealing with, that was,
the thought of declining or
flattening versus growing,
was I using, the best use of my time?
But intuitively, I knew
that everybody would watch YouTube videos.
Where I made a huge mistake
was I made a financial one.
If you remember this, there
was a start-up called Vidler
that let you tag, so, everybody was making
30 second videos, I was
making 20 minute videos,
and I was tasting wines
every seven minutes,
so I, this start-up came
to me and offered me
seven percent of their company,
because I was, like, the
breakout YouTube star,
to move over and exclusively go on Vidler,
and they had this tech
that was IP protected,
so you could just click the third wine
and just start watching,
YouTube didn't have that yet,
still, you know, so,
it was a huge mistake.
It was the one time in my career
I made a financial mistake,
I picked finances over where I thought
the market would spend their time.
You know, and so, I just, I knew,
guys, you know this is gonna happen.
Like, it's super cool,
like, this is fun for me,
like, this is why I love innovation.
You get that thrill again.
I'm sure you have this feeling right now.
Because I have it with this space.
It's that same feeling.
You know, it's probably why
discovering bands is fun, right?
Like, I'm sure the people
that are great at it are like,
when they see it, they see it, like,
do you know how cool it
is that every one of you,
right now, are either
gonna have your thing win,
or in 10 years, the thing
you're working on right now
in a different iteration is gonna win?
Like, either in 10 years,
you're gonna be like,
"Let me tell you how I did it,"
or you're gonna be like,
"Hey, you know this thing
that we're all doing, yeah, I did that
back in 2017.
(audience laughs)
we fucked it up, but, you know."
That's cool, you don't have
that now in other spaces.
You know.
Hope you guys enjoyed it.
Voice is the next frontier,
if you're looking to leapfrog,
because you were late on social media,
if you were late on Instagram
or a vlog or a podcast,
the voice platform, hope you
enjoyed it, leave a comment,
what was the biggest takeaway?
(inspirational music)